hi everyone my name is priyana tarajan
and i'm the current director of the
frankie program in science in the
humanities at yale
i welcome you all warmly to the final
spring semester events this afternoon we
have a lot of exciting new events
planned for this fall including a talk
and musical performance by the
internationally acclaimed jazz composer
performer and former yale college
physics undergraduate alum as it turns
out vijay ayer
i would also like to remind you to
contribute to our ongoing learning by
doing project and submit videos of
do-at-home science projects to add to
our bank
anyway coming back to today we have an
exciting talk by one of our own
brilliant young scholars
a frankie fellow dr anna florence first
i would like to start by recognizing our
benefactors
mr and mrs richard and barbara frankie
their generosity is what makes this
flagship interdisciplinary program at
yale possible i'm delighted that mrs
frankie has joined us today
and i want to remember remind all of you
who are assembled that we are recording
this event and all participants will
therefore have their videos muted for
the duration of the talk
and any questions that you might have
that arise during the talk
may be submitted at any time in the q a
feature
nearly five years ago
when i took over as the director of the
frankie program
and had a wonderful long coffee with
rich frankie one of the first things i
told him that i wanted to do was to
expand the footprint of the extremely
successful frankie fellowship
and extend it to graduate students and
postdoctoral scholars at yale he was
incredibly enthusiastic and excited at
the possibility
of extending
the support for interdisciplinary
projects across the board to many more
yales
i am utterly delighted to introduce one
of our recent post-doctoral frankie
fellows
dr anna florence as our speaker today
the title of her talk is social and
structural contours of marginalization
in the context of covet 19. so anna is
amongst our cohort of graduate student
and post postdoctoral scholars who
get frankie uh
fellowship support money to seed
ambitious bold ideas
that cross disciplinary boundaries
during their time at yale
dr anna florence
who is a recent postdoctoral fellow from
the frankie program is a clinical
psychologist
who is originally from brazil with
experience in the institutionalization
and implementation of public
community-based mental health services
her scholarship focuses on hope on the
open dialogue approach and other
dialogic practices for people
experiencing psychosis and
she has worked on human rights and the
role of lived experience in transforming
systems practices and conceptions of
mental health she has recently joined
columbia university as a postdoctoral
fellow and also works with the on-track
ny engaging youth and young adults in
research and quality improvement to
support a learning health care system in
new york city
for her frankie project and this is what
really attracted us to her work and
alerted us
to the talent that she brings to this
wonderful project she aimed to address
the current understanding of the mental
health impacts of kovit 19 pandemic was
an extremely timely and urgent project
this unprecedented public health crisis
she claimed in her proposal begs a
comprehensive
understanding of the social economic
psychological and political
underpinnings of suffering
through a strong multi-disciplinary
focus she suggested that she would look
at ways to expand
the ways in which mental health impact
of covid19 is conceptualized
inviting the voices of those who have
gone through mental health challenges in
the past and have accrued valuable
wisdom in their recovery journey to the
fore
she offered to hold a series of
consensus groups guided by her previous
research on this topic to develop this
new conceptual framework
broadening our understanding of this
crisis to include the social dimension
of experiences of suffering
can inform public policy and future
research to better respond collectively
to this global emergency so i was just
reading out of a wonderful super
compelling proposal that we got a couple
of years ago and and i'm delighted to
tell you that anna will be talking to us
today about this wisdom project this
project which was born in the wake of
the covet 19 pandemic
and what she has done and will be
talking to us today is to
reacquaint us with a group of persons
with lived experience with mental health
problems
and um for whom she has produced a
series of webinars
with whom for whom she has produced a
series of webinars podcasts and
conducted research on how we can
collectively make sense of this hugely
disrupt disruptive phenomenon
this pandemic far from being a great
equalizer which is what we all
originally thought right has brought to
four the issues that are at the very
core of our very inequitable societies
that we can no longer ignore systemic
racism oppression poverty and health
inequities
and access to healthcare inequities her
talk today will focus on a series of
regional conversations that invited the
voices and experiences of those who have
endured firsthand what it's like to
survive precarious livelihoods racism
oppression marginalization stigma and
other unfreedoms
we are
excited and utterly delighted to have
you speak to us today anna and we really
look forward to hearing more about this
wonderful frankie project anna take it
away
thank you so much priya that was a
wonderful introduction i'm just gonna
start sharing my screen and
we'll ask someone to confirm if you can
see my slides
looks great
perfect thank you so much
um so i would first like to start by
also thanking uh the frankie program for
the support of this work um i don't
think this work could ever have happened
without it
and as priya was mentioning it aligned
so well with the mission of the frankie
um program in science and the humanities
at yale and that this um i think one of
the pieces that
really fit well with the work that i was
already previously doing
is the interdisciplinary um
piece and so i really want to start by
saying that i didn't do this work alone
and by centering my colleagues and
everyone that was involved
through these past i'd say two years
this research has has been happening um
and i really wanted to also say that we
were a team and a collective of scholars
and activists
and we came from various different
backgrounds from psychologists to
sociologists to
historians and we came from different
countries
folks who participated were based in
brazil in canada and here in the united
states
um and one
important feature of this entire project
that i would like to center is that a
number of participants of the core
um team were people who had first-hand
experience of mental health challenges
or madness or extreme states or however
um
people went to conceptualize and
identify as and i think that this was uh
a core and very important feature
um of this group and also the work that
we did um in the various engagements
attempted to be as participatory as we
could and i think we can claim
uh here and say that our work was
actually led by people who had
um first hand or direct experience with
the mental health system
um
so with that i'd like to start by saying
a little bit about what this wisdom
project uh was and how it um
how it emerged
so initially once the pandemic started
we were all doing research and i bet
that people on this call were also doing
research that seemed quite relevant at
the moment and
and then with this huge disruption that
happened uh
we felt like at least in our group
that we had to shift priorities and
maybe uh
start doing some research or
maybe just even getting together i think
was the initial initial thought
um
around understanding what the impact
would be for uh people's mental health
challenges or people who are in the
mental health system
um
two narratives emerged very early on in
the pandemic
about um
mental health
and
two and one of the and part of this work
was to actually challenge some of these
conceptualizations that emerged uh very
early on
one of them is that
the the coveted 19 pandemic would bring
a tsunami of mental illness
this was
something that the media
was talking about but it was something
that also
made its way into academic
literature and research and it was
it looked pretty early on that uh
conceptualizations of how people would
respond
to
a global emergence of an unknown virus
that was killing people by the thousands
uh daily
that that would be framed as
a mental talent or a mental illness
and that really kind of got our
antennas up and because
there is a history in our field of
centering attention to the individual
rather than understanding
the social determinants of why
human suffering happens in certain
circumstances and why it manifests the
way it does um so this was kind of one
initial thing that we felt or our group
felt like we needed the challenge early
on
um and then the other response to a
tsunami of mental illness is to ramp up
services um so the idea that more people
would become ill and more people would
need services
would prompt a response in
increasing access to service increasing
services offered
and
we also wanted to challenge that in
in and include
a more so a more
a view more grounded and rooted
in social determinants of health rather
than individual
pathology if i can put it that way
and that's not to say that there isn't
suffering
but it's really how do we
understand suffering in such an extreme
context and how do we
draw the line of what suffering is
appropriate acceptable normal and what
suffering and what suffering warrants
treatment services diagnoses
so really what with the pandemic kind of
re-centered are some questions that
are part of psychiatry and are part of
this so-called side disciplines
um
since their emergence as disciplines and
so they're not really new problems but
they were just kind of uh
centered
uh very suddenly uh once the
the response kind of the world response
uh to
the pandemic started being
conceptualized as
mental illness
and another um element that
pretty early on also appeared in in the
narrative
um
is this idea of crisis as opportunity
um and for a cure some curious reason
for something different entirely i was
rereading
uh susan sontag's um
one of the books that she wrote that's
called illness as a metaphor
and
in in in reading it the book actually
comes with two the the book that i got
is two books of hers and one is
illnesses metaphor and then the other is
aids in its metaphors and that's a book
she she wrote about the apes epidemic
um
and i was just surprised to see a type
of
prophetic uh
kind of content in this book and as i
read it i felt like i could just
uh switch words and
and kind of see a complete repetition of
something that had happened in the past
with the aids epidemic
uh including the
inequities and inequalities that were
seen in the day but all back uh with the
aids epidemic but also
some of the metaphors that it um
instilled
and it was just very interesting to
also she she quotes um
the the at the time um
head of the wh show saying things very
similar to what we were hearing uh the
current head of the whole say so it was
quite
interesting to see how
um
history repeats itself and and how it's
not always that we learned something
from from history
so
in terms of the crisis is opportunity
that that's an interesting idea but we
wanted to challenge in the sense that
is opportunity for whom and who takes
this opportunity um and and how is
crisis being conceptualized um i think
all of this uh
for instance for the global north this
looked a certain way with the pandemic
with the vaccines and with the ability
to provide services but then in the
global south it certainly looked very
different
and for instance one of our colleagues
was based in brazil was doing some
research around
um
how you know covet was being experienced
in
in the favelas of brazil and then
for you know the people that they were
interviewing that wasn't a crisis at all
it was just another thing uh crisis were
related to
hunger to not having food to not having
a roof over your head and to
problems of basic subsistence that
uh were really much more important
than you know another virus
and so this idea of crisis is is an idea
that's
uh that has
a place and that has um a context to
exist
and also this idea of opportunity uh
opportunity for whom and what type of
opportunity and also did we take this
this opportunity is something that
that was on our mind
um so today i'll talk about
how we went about uh
addressing these issues
uh how do we engage and understand this
um
the way we did it is just by going to
the source um i think that we
early on came up with a number of
strategies to engage with people in
multiple different ways
both through ways that would be
considered research but also
in other ways we did a number of
webinars and podcasts that i'll talk
about
we wrote a commentary and published it
we did a listening session so it was
really a mix of
a lot of different ways to engage with
people and we ended up
um
i think engaging with uh many more than
we would have expected at the beginning
so what i'll do today in my talk is talk
a little bit about
those listening sessions what we learned
there and how that informed
uh the following stages of of this
project
what we published the podcast series
that we did
uh the webinars and finally the focus
groups and and those were the regional
conversations that were national in
uh kind of geography and
um
and kind of finishing up with some final
thoughts that i hope won't be too
disappointing
and every time i see researchers talking
i hear you know i'm
good at asking more questions and never
answering anything and i feel like i
might
um i might be blamed for the same
problem but i'll do my best
to keep us all engaged in this
conversation
i should also add that there is a reason
why we wanted to discuss
uh marginalization
um and in mental health and
and oppression so those
those issues
i mean as prio was saying at the
beginning um if folks thought and i feel
like i was naive enough to think that
this might be the great equalizer and
that it would affect everyone and so
maybe this would bring us together
i guess really early days i was trying
to
remain optimistic but then very very
early on
uh
we saw incredible disparities and and
that the pandemic was really affecting
people in very very different ways um
and that and those different ways are
not random those different ways are
related to the inequities and the
structural issues that
have been part of society for
a long long time
and have gone unaddressed and then came
uh squarely to the fore um as the
pandemic emerged
and i'll just give a brief i don't want
to drawn draw
too many uh statistics for for this talk
because my research is mostly
qualitative and i like to be
uh very close to what people tell us and
you'll see that there will be a lot of
quotes as we move along but
i'll just uh say that for a person
diagnosed with a mental disorder uh
mortality of covet was much higher than
persons without a diagnosis
and within the the
this group of people with the
psychiatric diagnosis people diagnosed
with schizophrenia had an even higher
mortality rate and that is considered um
a serious
mental illness
um and then i'll
also
add that when compared to white
americans and adjusted for age african
americans are 3.6 times more likely
um native americans are 3.4 times more
likely and latinx are 3.2 times more
likely to die from cobit 19.
um
so that really also informed
a lot of our work
and so
those were very sobering
things that we learned early on i i want
to say that
i i wish i wish it it surprised me but
uh once we started learning and once the
research started coming out
um
i have to say that anyone that's in this
area knows that um that these inequities
are in place and it was expected that
they would affect people
uh differently
so i wanted to start
by
presenting the listening sessions that
we had
um so listening sessions are just a way
of of convening people and a slightly
informal uh forum without much of an
agenda
uh this was so early this was april uh
2021 so this is very early on um
in the pandemic
and
what we really wanted to do was to
understand whether people had had a
previous experience with the mental
health system whether it be being
hospitalized because of a mental health
um issue or having had a diagnosis of a
mental disorder um
how people were
understanding the pandemic and how were
they
and this this has a history it comes
from an idea that um
also
was a narrative that early on emerges
that people who have a previous
uh diagnosis of mental health challenges
would likely
be more affected or affected in a worse
way or have poor outcomes than uh people
without a diagnosis
and
so we just wanted to understand a little
bit how people were
dealing with having to isolate and
having to shelter in place and
um and just kind of it was a it was a
very informal set of conversations to
lay the groundwork for the other
engagements that we did
and so a couple of themes that i thought
would be interesting to share with you
is that
first of all so many experts emerged um
as the pandemic um
hit and one of the questions that that
we heard in our listening sessions were
who are the experts
uh so all this stuff about surviving a
pandemic and that's a direct quote of a
participant
expert advice as if anybody alive has
experienced a pandemic before and is an
expert in it
so i think that um that that was very
interesting because psychologists
psychiatrists and mental health
professionals were being called
uh to talk about the pandemic and and
kind of the mental health impact of it
and it was it's just very interesting
because this is one instance where we
are all going through it together and i
can't really say as a
say a clinical psychologist myself that
i have
more experience than someone that i'm
seeing as a
a client or a patient
than them and so in that sense it kind
of levels the power
dynamics between
um
professionals and and non-professionals
so that was something that came up early
on and we also hoped um that that would
allow us to think more critically about
these power imbalances that
um are part of therapeutic relationships
and in that the expert knows more about
you than yourself and kind of flip that
on its head and think that
well maybe the the expert on on on my
own life is is me
and not the person that i'm seeing as a
professional
and that's something that's part of of
kind of the critical
uh work in this area in the area of
mental health and
um so there was some hope that maybe we
could talk more about these issues now
that
um everyone would be going through this
pandemic together and kind of
experiencing it at the same
time and it'd be very hard to claim
um
being an expert any more than any other
person
so that was an interesting thing we
learned there
um and then also some knowledge and
wisdom from direct experience um
with mental health with hospitalizations
and and and with you know maybe
even coercive uh mental health kind of
treatments
um
and then i think one one thing we we
list we heard a number of times that
people have lived experience have lived
experience in trauma but they also have
lived experience in recovery
and so in some ways in these listening
sessions we heard a lot that
um
some of this that
you know a previous history with the
mental health challenge
could be seen as putting people in a
more vulnerable position was actually
being conceptualized by the people that
we were listening to by
actually having had some experience that
is useful
for this context uh and being sometimes
more prepared than their counterparts
who never
um
had any
lived experience with trial or direct
experience with trauma or psychiatric
diagnosis
um so that was an interesting uh take on
things as well maybe
uh what was thought as a vulnerability
is actually
uh kind of an asset
um something else that we heard that
that was
interesting and not surprising to me but
might be surprising to some is a lot of
people said well welcome to my life uh
some people have to self-isolate anyway
because of chronic illness or other
conditions that make it harder for them
to get out and they're like welcome to
my experiences on a regular basis
um and we heard different things as well
so we heard from people who are
hospitalized multiple times for instance
that
you know they they were told what to do
before this is not the first time that
they're being told that they can't leave
the room that they can't leave
um
or that they can't do something that
they wanted to do
and so
not to romanticize those experiences or
say that it's good to go through trauma
because that protects you from even more
traumatic experiences in the future
but just to say that some of the
assumptions that
about fragility and about vulnerability
uh related to how you know people go
through these experiences may not um
map out to to their real experiences
and and one huge concern that that came
up time and time again um
was i think kind of the driver of this
whole of this whole project is i wonder
now
i wonder how we can counter that
narrative and not have this be an
opportunity to funnel more people into
the mental health system
i worry that that's will go that's where
we'll go instead of social change and
addressing disparities issues
and i think this direct quote from one
of our participants really
uh
was kind of decisive for for taking uh
the route that that we did
and so those listening sessions really
shaped uh all the other engagements that
uh that we planned for for this project
beyond the research piece but you'll see
that we also had
um
the webinars and the podcasts were more
related to engaging with people rather
than to extract data
um
and then i'll all show show us a quote
that really was one of the most striking
for me early on and made me
it was really provocative
um
so someone in our listening session said
when i went psychotic people talked
about me personally breaking from
reality but it seems like reality is
breaking from all of us so what do you
call that
um and that was a very
to me uh
important provocation in terms of how we
conceptualize mental illness mental
health challenges mental problems
however you want to call it
um
what happens when when
you know something so disruptive happens
in reality
uh and shared and consensual right in
consensus reality what what do we call
it
and that from those listening sessions
we actually wrote a commentary uh which
we published and the commentary was
co-authored by a number of people
who are not academics who are people who
have had a previous diagnosis and mental
health diagnosis or people who are
activists and so this was this is one
example of uh
kind of how how it's possible to
maybe bridge some of these uh
gaps between academia and activism or
academia and
kind of
regular life i would say
and that we really invited um everyone
who participated in the listening
sessions to be co-authors and it was
really written
by multiple hands and
and so we published that early on uh
when reality breaks from us lived
experienced wisdom and coven 19 area
era
and we did outline some of those themes
and and kind of thought about some
directions for the future
and then
the other piece that uh that we that we
did and
i mean we just didn't want to do
research only we wanted to take the
interdisciplinary aspect of things to
another level in that we not only wanted
to do research between different
disciplines but we also wanted to engage
different media
and engage um
you know people
that are sitting in different places
uh including some policy makers and some
of the names that you'll see there are
policy makers and and some people who
are you know working within the system
and then a mix with people who
have lived experience or direct
experience
um and so we did this podcast series um
in which we
just talked rather quite informally
about the issues that were coming up
and
uh so that was in partnership with c4
innovations and the mental health
technology transfer
center for the new england region
and
a lot of we covered a lot of topics from
like surviving the mental health system
to alternative understandings of human
suffering to
peer support work to social justice and
racial equity
and so
it really we kind of came up with the
themes uh together based on what we were
hearing in our listening sessions but
also what our core team was
um kind of indicating would be
um
an interesting direction to go and the
types of resources that we thought
people might want but might not have
access to
um
and then we also did this webinar series
that was also kind of early on um
and we did three separate webinars that
was also in partnership with the mental
health technology transfer center and
that reached a national audience
and folks from canada as well we had a
number of states represented in these
uh and these calls
and they're available for anyone who
just want to go into the website
um
and so we one we did one uh based on
that initial theme welcome to my world
uh then we did one on social justice and
cover 19 and we also did one on peer
support and essential workers
um i just want to check how i'm doing on
time okay okay
and now i just want to uh transition to
kind of the more researchy phase of this
project i it's just a
a mix of different methods and different
things and we really wanted to make sure
that we were
kind of weaving in
um
research and activism and engaging and
connecting with people and not just
not just doing research so
sometimes i look at this and i and i
wonder is this a slightly disjointed
methodology but in fact it was really
the result of
us trying to figure out how to navigate
the space and how to kind of rapidly
respond to
the needs that we were seeing
um
just in our daily lives it just felt
like everyone was going through
everything at the same time and you
don't have you know the luxury of
hindsight or
of time
so
with that kind of preliminary work and
those
engagements that we had uh early on
then we went to
we went ahead and had a number of focus
groups
and that was a very long process for for
our team to kind of develop
what we wanted to ask people but also
how we wanted to
capture
um
vulnerability marginalization and the
experiences that we were looking to
understand
um
and so
we through an iterative process of going
over the
the themes that we saw in the listening
sessions but also
you know being current with the
literature that was coming out on this
subject
we developed um
some areas of focus that we thought
would be really important to um
to touch on
and so we ended up
landing on these
themes and then when we recruited people
were invited to self-select uh to the
group that they felt uh was closer to
their experience
and so for that we had experiences with
mental health and substance use during
the pandemic and we did actually two
focus groups with that subject or that
topic
we had experiences of poverty and then
um
people self-selected to that group as
well
experiences with invisibility and virus
exposure and that was
related to
essential workers people who were not
able to shelter in place
such as bus drivers or people in
essential servers like janitorial
services and hospitals
um
there was a lot of attention to you know
how much healthcare professionals were
exposed to the virus but there was an
entire
contingent of people who were
working daily never sheltered in place
and made sure that services continued
um and that were not um
you know uh clapped to and applauded and
thanked uh by society and in fact we're
getting sick and we're dying and we're
uh in this kind of invisibility uh
position
um and so we wanted to make sure that we
talked to to people who had that
experience
um
and then experiences with housing and
food insecurity
um we also wanted to know how people
experienced kind of the rapid emergence
of some benefits that you know
were maybe long due but
suddenly when the pandemic started you
know there was the
eviction moratorium there was you know a
number of different benefits that people
could access there were hotel rooms for
for people who were experiencing
homelessness
and so it just seemed like a lot of
things that
um
people were advocating for for a very
long time
suddenly became possible and we really
wanted to understand
um
how people who had have had these
experiences in the past
uh were dealing with it now and the
impact of these new programs that
emerged after covet
we also understood very clearly that
incarcerated populations were being
kind of left behind in many ways
with covid and so we wanted to make sure
that we also centered those experiences
and we also wanted to talk to activists
and understand what happened to activism
and
you know did everything shift focus when
the pandemic started was activism you
know galvanized by this or or did it die
out so we were really
interested in kind of hearing more about
that as well
so as i mentioned it was a a joint
process of developing these themes
uh to make sure that we captured a wide
gamut of of experiences of vulnerability
marginalization and oppression that
people could be
experiencing
so the way we were to disseminate this
and to recruit folks was we used a
number of activism related
serves and just our personal kind of
connections but also
yeah i mean just any type of list serve
it was really we cast a wide white net
and we really ended up getting folks
from you know all over the country
participating in these conversations
um
so we ended up for this stage uh having
36 participants who joined several seven
focus groups
and so that's just some of the
characteristics of people who
participated the mean age was 48 years
old
for those who did answer uh question the
demographics questions
uh we had 19 female three male and one
fluid non-binary person
uh six participants identified as black
or african american identify as biracial
and 14 is white and then a number of
people didn't fill out
the demographics so we don't have very
complete data on that
16 reported having one or more
psychiatric diagnoses and eight reported
substance use challenge
nine reported having one or more
disabilities
um eight of the participants reported
being on ssi or ssdi or receiving other
benefits
to reported history of homelessness
uh five participants had a history of
incarceration or a family or of a family
member who had been incarcerated
um
most participants reported multiple and
intersecting vulnerabilities
and six participants had coveted
themselves and another three had close
family members who had coveted
and so the first thing that was
kind of surprising i guess it shouldn't
be but it was because a lot of the
research and a lot of the media
narrative sometimes like makes us think
that things are
linear and
kind of um homogeneous but in fact when
we started talking to people
a lot of people described the the kind
of the whole experience of of co of the
pandemic as in a positive light
and for found silver linings or found
very positive
um
things that happened uh as a result of
the pandemic
and
but most people certainly described uh
challenges and that's obviously also by
virtue of what we wanted to talk about
but one of the positive things that
people talked about was to be able to
reconnect with family around the world
via zoom and so feeling more connected
um
some people really described it as it
was a nightmare um i recycled to
supplement my food and my many other
needs and i couldn't do it for the first
month we were all locked down
and then afterwards still to this state
not safe i don't feel safe
um safe doing anymore
um and then some people describe their
experiences just neutral so i think it
wasn't that disruptive for me simply
because i'm older and i'm more set in my
ways i have the same routine i've had
for years plus i'm able to entertain
myself because i have a lot of
electronic entertainment in my home
and so we heard mixed things like we
kind of went in um
maybe with our assumptions that it would
be a really challenging experience for
everyone but
uh yeah we learned that there was just
this wide heterogeneity of how people
experience it but not just how they
experienced but how they talked about it
in terms of um isolation and
connectedness i feel like that was the
theme that came up a lot most
participants really emphasize isolation
loneliness and lack of
connection um
so one example here i was so
disconnected so alone and in a psychotic
state that i really needed people i was
just too isolated
um so some people did describe that
and
then uh what else here so what we saw
was that people not only were using the
previous connected channels through
their local clubhouses but were
interacting beyond the scope of their
of their small community
um and that and so that's one example of
connectedness right so this is in the
context of having like 12-step groups um
online and then um
some you know therapeutic groups and and
meetings that when you know beyond their
their communities and actually reached
uh many more people than they would have
imagined
um
[Music]
in terms of the stimulus checks and
other benefits most participants who
receive them
found them to be very helpful and some
even experienced uh financial and
housing stability for the first time in
in very many years
um so a participant here i've lived in a
cycle of poverty almost my entire life
and basically when i was raising my
daughter was the only time i was really
stable as far as financially goes
and then just recently with the stimulus
and unemployment very helpful
um we also heard a lot and i think that
that experience
certainly uh transcends any uh
i guess any vulnerability or
marginalization but the times feeling
very politically fraught and
participants talked a lot about you know
polarized views and and difficulties
just navigating very politically charged
conversations
um and then one um
one example i guess as
we can see here
um i would love to get another stimulus
check but i don't think we deserve it i
saw too many people using it for reasons
that they shouldn't have used it for so
i don't think we deserve another
stimulus check
um and then so so some of this was in
very um
kind of charged context and and with
very strong views
and then uh others here i i've stopped
talking about cove in 19 to people
because it's become so politicized and
my family i'm not going to get um
a lot into them
and so
this feeling was really um
it came it came up a lot and with very
strong views about very various
different issues
in terms of activism and people had been
um
activists before
um
they really described this kind of
an awareness of the need to continue
activism but also a sense of urgency
that may have not been there before
um and so one example here i'm not sure
that i increased my activism or
decreased definitely didn't decrease
during the pandemic but it definitely
became a bit more urgent i would say
um
and then another participant here i
figured out a way to shake the
foundation i got active
it wasn't that i really wanted to become
active but i probably should have been
doing this a long time ago
but it stood up my activism of how i
could change the outcomes of someone in
certain circumstances that i was
witnessing so we we didn't hear a lot of
that in in the focus groups that
people just felt
activated
and then in terms of poverty financial
challenges associated with the pandemic
and the benefits um that people received
that that those were discussed quite
extensively
um
and then i would just read you know the
participants um
quotes and financially i work one
full-time job in two part-time jobs all
at the same place
i lost the two part-time jobs so
it was a struggle to pay my bills but
i'm making it it's hard and i still have
anxiety attack from it
uh someone else say oh health-wise you
know i'm not working anymore i went on
ssdi my sister said you know financially
i took a big hit
um
someone else said i've lost money
there's a monetary things thing in terms
of being infected i had just had surgery
but during covet i've been a part-time
musician i couldn't do any gigs so i
lost money that's a lot of money
um
and then someone but then i was eligible
for the pandemic unemployment and that
was really helpful i started building my
credit return to college to study cyber
security and that's good and paid off my
driver's license fine fines was able to
send my brother
who was incarcerated some money and was
able to get my daughter some money
so really um overwhelmingly uh positive
experiences with receiving additional
benefits
um
and then in terms of injustices that
people talked about um
i
some some people said i've spent
uh a lot of it a lot of the pandemic uh
being very angry with a lot of people
including government officials
i'm trying to work my way through that
and in realizing that some policy
decisions that that they made that
seemed profoundly inequitable especially
for people's disabilities at the time
um and then just
everyone should be treated equally
because we're all human beings
uh we all are where we where you come
from if you're black or white rich or
poor you should be treated with dignity
when you are sick
um
and then we also had you know racism was
a topic that came up in most of the
groups that
that we did
and then in various different ways which
shouldn't be surprising either
um
so one one quote here and and here is
one way i think everyone here has agreed
that clearly we've got a racist system
here that's deadly we got that
and then someone talking about their own
experience it took me back to when i was
11 years old when i was stopped by the
police and they frisked me and they
checked me and they said i looked like
someone who had committed a crime
at 11 years old i knew that i could be
vulnerable for certain things
covet has let me know has let me also
know
about the disparities in health care
poor people black people and brown
people have been such high numbers
and then one i i was kind of um
divided of whether i should keep this
quote or not but i decided to to keep it
here and read it um i was not
i certainly had never and i've been in
the united states for three years now as
priya mentioned i'm originally from
brazil and i i don't think i had ever
encountered something as direct as this
before
um and that may be you know by virtue of
being an academic center but
um
i i should read this quote and say that
you know one of our participants said
very clearly but i tell people i am
racist and i will be racist till the day
i die
i grew up in a racist family seeing a
black man walking down the street and
calling him up n word was nothing to me
in st paul when i was growing up but to
me i can be friends with someone who's
native american i can be friends with
someone who's african-american but i
don't like the organization i don't like
black lives matter i don't like the
other stuff but i have friends who are
all different races and stuff so yeah
it's kind of a catch-22 if i can say
that
so
it was really um
a very broad um i guess
i guess this was one participant out of
the 36 that we interviewed and the
majority of views aligned with
the views that you see on the previous
two quotes but
that's just an example
i guess of how
much work we still have to do around
racial equity about anti-racism work
um because um
i feel like people some people might
still be very comfortable in in saying
what this participant said for instance
and i also wanted to bring some
attention to you know what limitations
we had in these
groups that we convened i think one of
them
is that participants really learned
about this this study a lot a lot of
them via
activism networks and so
we could expect that these uh could be
people who are just more likely to be
engaged or who have you know
less challenges with
technology for instance and
um so we might have missed you know a
lot of the people that we did want to
engage just by virtue of how we
recruited folks
um
and
and so some final thoughts that i want
to um and this is my last slide and i
i'm moving towards the end of my talk
and
would be really interested in
engaging in conversation with with
everyone that's um
that's in the room but
one of the i think
key things that
we as researchers but um
and as policy makers and as clinicians
and wherever we're sitting i think we
need to think a little bit about
how a lot of the mental health discourse
is sometimes
obliterating some
really important issues related to
poverty related to
um
social determinants of health and and
related to issues that are more
uh systemic in our society rather than
at the individual level
i think one challenge is how to actually
connect those various levels both
conceptually so that our practices can
be more guided
towards you know approaches that are
informed
um
by these multiple determinants
um
but also in in terms of what type of
research where money is being invested
where funding goes for these types of
things
um if we want to ramp up services or do
we want to
expand you know as a social
you know net so that people don't fall
through the cracks so much and that you
know people actually have an opportunity
to climb out of the poverty cycle that a
lot of participants talked about
um
they're also so this was conceptualized
by some authors by helena henson for
instance as pathologizing poverty but
joanna moncrief was a
another author also
uh conceptualize it as medicalizing
misery and a lot of it has happened
after you know welfare reform um in the
united states after
you know 1996
in that really one of the few pathways
towards
more stable benefits currently in the
united states is through a psychiatric
diagnosis or chronic pain
um
and that has uh impacts and and helena's
work shows that way beyond
uh having a disability uh but also the
subjective and impacts of
having to
identify yourself as someone who's
disabled and also the stigma that that
brings for for people actually
end up institutionalizing
ways of being in the world and and forms
of existence
um so it has damage i mean it has the
potential to create uh harm
uh way beyond some of the more directly
and easily anticipated
um
results
of a
kind of a welfare system that is
structured in this way that a lot of
kind of the gatekeeping happens through
through the medical uh system
and
i think this idea of crisis as a golden
opportunity that's also i mean that was
kind of just a direct quote from one of
the papers that came out early on
in the pandemic
i mean it really makes you wonder i mean
the pandemic hasn't really been a great
equalizer at all if anything it just
revealed even more
uh clearly the the
horrendous uh inequities both in in
health and and
and the systemic racism is something
that came to the fore
um
very acutely uh in this time the
oppression poverty
um you know lack of universal health
care in the you know richest country of
the world
is something that
you know it's a discussion that i
i didn't
see a lot of
um and and so
was it really a golden opportunity or
have we missed it is there still time
those are questions that i that i
continue to ask myself
um it really
certainly was not the great equalizer i
don't know what we're gonna start seeing
now that the more the eviction
moratorium
uh was lifted and what the consequences
will will be of rolling back
uh some of the supports that were put in
place once the when the pandemic started
and you know
what are going to be the consequences of
of you know the
economic crisis coupled with
um a sudden loss of of the few supports
that people had
um access to just to stay afloat
and
really so i think that kind of the
takeaway message here for us was that
you know there's a there's a need to
articulate these equally important
levels of the issue
so the direct experience and the
individual
and how people were suffering or
struggling is an incredibly
important element but how are they
weaved in and connected with the more
systemic
uh and societal
uh levels and and how can we actually
address those things uh beyond the just
the individual
um
and then i also think that one of the
successful
elements of of this work was that it it
really centered the voices of of people
who had first-hand experiences in
every stage of research from planning to
to executing to analyzing the the data
into planning next steps
and so
i continue to advocate and be a firm
believer that we can only find solutions
for
these complicated issues if we center
um the voices and the experiences of
those who are most affected by it
and so i think this is a good time to
um wrap up i
again i'm so thankful for this
invitation and i hope that we can have a
discussion together in a conversation uh
so thank you very much again to to priya
and tai for putting this together and to
the frankies for supporting this work
thank you so much anna for sharing these
wonderful insights uh from this project
um if i may there is a question in the
chat but if i may um open up by asking
the first question myself
i was curious about you mentioned that
there were people
who felt um even though they were um you
know quite economically disadvantaged
they felt that they didn't deserve
the second um uh check right
and
i was curious as to
what you gathered about that kind of
mental frame uh those people carried
is that a frame where they felt
themselves that they were a burden on
society was it some kind of um is this
the way in which did it reflect do you
think how they viewed
their social status
as how they view it or how society views
them
and that this is something they have
internalized so i was very curious
about people and their reactions to what
would be seen as entitlements right
social um entitlement social safety net
entitlements
yeah i really appreciate that question
and i think it's something that i myself
am grappling with how to understand that
in the moment when i heard it um and it
wasn't endorsed only by one participant
two other participants in the same group
endorsed the same view
and just to provide a little bit of
context there the um
really this was a group um this was the
focus group about poverty and so
these were uh persons who really without
the
the benefits uh or without the stimulus
check and without other benefits that
impacted housing
would find themselves either without
housing and on the streets or completely
just unable to to survive and so
for me
and and this is an act of interpretation
because in the moment it was really
difficult to to understand because it
was just a very fixed idea that
um
that just receiving and the idea was
really articulated as receiving money
from the government is always bad
and i think it was really a clash of
ideas about the american way of life and
ideas about you know what pulling
yourself by the bootstraps
look like and all of these kind of
tropes of independence and of freedom
uh that actually clash very directly
with some you know
direct needs that people might have or
ways in which you know the government
that reality right their
reality of their lives right yeah but it
is interesting that you would stick with
the with the tropes and with the myths
rather than uh than with reality itself
and then
you know this would be an interesting
topic of
just more as an inquiry just to
understand how these things
interact
yeah and i and i think that one of the
reasons i picked that up uh from what
you were saying is you know the rhetoric
with the uh the right wing a camp if you
will
uh is that and sort of the fiscally
conservative uh
members of um
citizens of the country is that somehow
these sort of people who are on welfare
uh would just chronically love to be on
welfare and they want to continue to be
on welfare and they are happy to exploit
the state
so i think this would be very very
useful to counter that narrative
right that is not sort of a uniformly
held position there is a sense of
dignity in which as you said people want
to hang on to these tropes
um
at the expense of their own individual
needs at the time right
so
that is sort of what i found really sort
of intriguing about this
and out of curiosity were they often
people who had dependents were they
single mothers who said this or were
they single people or
is it too hard to classify a demographic
and say something no that i mean that is
one participant that i remember very
well and um this was a married man with
uh yeah with children and grandchildren
and
yeah i mean the the other piece is that
you that goes
kind of
in in
in discourse kind of appeared side by
side with this idea of a cycle of
poverty that is impossible to get out of
and
so it was interesting to see that you
know this idea of people loving being on
benefits doesn't really square out with
the fact that people are actually
struggling with benefits and even to
come out of benefits it feels like a
cycle that is impossible to break
and so those contradictions um i mean
those were really interesting to see and
i think that we saw them also at like
the highest political levels
um in in this country and in my country
in brazil certainly as well
um
so yeah it's an interesting phenomena i
i hope that someone is looking into that
because i just don't have very good
answers to understand how that thinking
kind of evolves
um thank you so much so there's a
question from gerald jordan who asked
great talk really interesting findings
and it's amazing how you reached beyond
academic boundaries to work with so many
different kinds of people
what do you feel was the most rewarding
part of doing this work
yeah and i think this is a great
question i think that you know when you
look at this entire project it seems um
we did so many different things and i
feel like that was really
um
i think that what was rewarding and what
i really liked about it is that we were
able to kind of create our path as we as
we went along and so
i think a lot of it was just building
from what we were listening and then
being able to um identify where we had
to go next and then and then doing it
so i think that this responsiveness to
kind of what we were seeing in in
practice is hardly ever possible in the
academic world where you have to plan
everything ahead
and say what you're going to do and then
do it
so i think that this kind of
flipping of of the order of things and
being able to just have a very adaptive
um
setup was to me uh interesting and
really i just like to
to work with people i think that the
other rewarding piece is just to
um have people who are not academics uh
working with us in this group
um and i think it really pushes the work
like closer to the ground and and keeps
things
um
more relevant um
i think so i appreciate the question
and a wonderful talk of course we were
expecting it to be and it really
delivered
i wanted to know if you could talk a bit
more about what you learned about the
human capacity for resilience it's a
double-edged sword as you pointed out
because of course it comes
after great suffering um the more
resilient you are it's probably because
you've suffered that much more but what
lessons might
you be able to derive as a psychologist
from people you know from resiliency and
how
maybe aspects of resiliency might be
applied
uh to people who find themselves in in
extremely difficult circumstances like
health uh
problems such as a pandemic
yeah
thanks ty that's um
that's a thorny question
i'll respond to the the best way i can
and it's actually funny that you ask
because
uh resilience became kind of a um a
buzzword that's even hard to to kind of
define right now um it's being used in
so many ways i think a lot of it
my personal problem with this concept is
really how it places again the emphasis
on the individual
and i think that that's really um
why i always whenever i talk about you
know vulnerability and resilience i
i always do that with the caveat that
um
we really need to find better ways to
kind of conceptualize these ideas in
including more societal levels and kind
of environmental
aspects and obviously the individual is
always in the picture and we don't want
to be like we just don't want to exclude
the individual either and for someone
who's
a clinician for instance who's you know
before
pure suffering right if you're with a
person and and that's what you're seeing
that is the most important thing in the
moment
um so that's not to say that the
individual is not important that
suffering doesn't exist but
i think that the field really struggles
with
um
conceptual frameworks that actually
connect these multiple levels of the
issue
and
the ways in which we conceptualize these
things really impact how we think about
treatment how we think about diagnosis
how we think about public policy and how
we put together
and how we set up systems of support and
how we change societal structures
and so it's not a naive
question to ask where does the
individual what is the place of the
individual what is the place of society
and where this suffering factor into all
of this
um it's actually a question that i feel
the the field has not done a good job at
answering and then we the pendulum
swings from from one side to the other
um and that we really have a hard time
uh thinking about complex issues
in ways that we can actually provide
supports for people uh while also
keeping in mind the the larger context
um
in our work
so that's kind of a long-winded a
typical academic answer
along with when did response no thank
you though thank you i mean uh if i may
follow up a bit you know one of the
things that
it seems a pitfall perhaps of of
trying to understand or derive some
broader benefit from
resiliency is that could it could it
lead to a kind of insouciance right so
someone who has suffered greatly before
might then say you know oh well i've
been through worse right and
and not then take precautions i was
wondering with the individuals you met
did you see some of that and uh and how
you might have worked with them if you
did at all or you were just listening to
how they
lived that that dichotomy
yeah that did come up
um a lot actually
um that yes i you know this
bring it on
you know i've seen worse or and and also
some people who said i didn't care about
exposure i just
um i didn't think that was a problem for
me so so that
that that is the the flip side of it
yeah it can make you strong but it can
also
uh
kind of devastate your your sense of
self-worth your sense of uh self-care
your ability to care for yourself and
i we heard a lot of that too
and and that is i think the
the flip side of the whole resilience
conversation is that
it can actually have dramatic and
devastating effects for people and even
though that they're there and it seems
like they're powering through
um
actually the experience itself is just
devastating
and so we did see that and and in that
way this is why whenever i say we see
immense resilience and we see
you know people are not as vulnerable as
we think they are at the same time i'm
always um calling attention to this
caveat that you're
you know we shouldn't be romanticizing
uh like extreme suffering as in fact i
mean even
it does prepare people in certain ways
to endure more suffering but is that
really what we want to accomplish as a
society right
it begs that question
so um
i i've had another question which is
we're really sort of trying to assess
the
the role of mental health post pandemic
do you see there being a real shift
in the recognition and the expansion of
this category of mental health
and what counts as um
you know illness and what counts as a
preventative
measures has the pandemic disruptive as
it has been
has it fundamentally shifted anything at
all um you think in terms of
how we view
i mean i don't think there is anybody
who survived the pandemic without mental
health consequences of some sort or the
other
for most of us uh who are fortunate they
were manageable but uh that it goes
without saying that it was a period of
extremists for all of us right
and uh has it really shifted the
conversation anna i mean are we going to
see any lasting effects of this once in
a generation i mean whatever once in a
hundred years sort of uh pandemic
that's good i mean that's
a good question i mean i don't know that
i can
make any predictions about but just your
sense of it your sense of my feeling is
that so one thing i feel did happen um
mental health is the most talked about
subject
um
i think that i i don't i cannot be in a
space
where mental health is not a topic i
feel like that's in the news every
single day
um and that you know this
initial kind of
prediction of there will be a tsunami of
mental illness that that which that was
said in the beginning of the pandemic
was kind of a self-fulfilling prophecy
in that
by
codifying and by understanding kind of
the reactions
that people were having to this enormous
disruption
as mental health problems i think that
by placing it in that conceptual
uh field
um
kind of created a lot of the situation
now the way we're talking about our
suffering and the way we're talking
about what happened to us during this
time is by saying that we're having
mental health problems
and you know that is true in in so many
ways i mean this is the way that we're
talking about our experience we're not
sleeping well we're not
um
we have anxiety we haven't seen people
in two years
children you know haven't left the house
in in years and interact with other kids
so all of these uh
kind of all these things that happen
because of the pandemic obviously are
going to have consequences that we don't
really anticipate
we don't really know
but the fact that the conversation is so
centered
in frame that this does concern me
slightly because it means that
the response that
how can we think of a response outside
of the
individual
kind of treatment realm
and more related to how can we survive
this as a society and what kind of
what kind of group of people do we want
to be
um i feel like it
kind of
um
puts that question to the side
when we focus so much on on individual
suffering
and i also think that for
people who are being diagnosed with
anxiety depression or whatever um
diagnosis you know we all might be
getting
um
how is that going to help us uh or and
that's a sincere question how is that
going to help us
make meaning and kind of find a way out
of this
um
more collective way rather than right
right i was going to say i mean i think
the key word here that you know you are
bringing to our attention uh repeatedly
is the the collective confrontation of
these problems
rather than delegating them to the
individual and of course in america
there's a very strong
self-help culture right that predates
the pandemic and i can only imagine that
you know we're soon going to be seeing
lots and lots of self-help books
you know get out of the pandemic funk
help yourself get out of the pandemic
funk and so on so forth right so
um yeah i share your anxiety that
despite the scope of this pandemic
it probably did not convert this society
our society from being so individualist
to a more communitarian collective
vision
uh sort of view and i think that
it's a
it's a it's sad that you know if this
didn't do it you know what else could
really shift us to
because i think as you point out right
there's a way in in which um you know
inequity is sort of embedded in this
individualism right so i mean i mean i'm
not going to get into the big questions
of how you know capitalism and hyper
capitalism and the difference between
the individual and the social models
uh east versus west i mean there have
been all these sort of simplifying you
know north versus south people have done
a lot of analysis right trying to argue
that there are some inescapable
consequences of a capitalist and a
hyper-capitalist society but i think if
any you know tsunami of an event could
have shifted the conversation shifted
the perspective
it was this pandemic i guess one can be
optimistic and say it's early days but
yeah are you optimist about that
i couldn't agree with you more priya i i
mean i
i feel like i have to be an optimist and
hold hope but i'm i'm also very
uncertain
um
yeah and i just wanted to acknowledge i
hadn't i didn't know that i could see
who the attendees are but wanted to
acknowledge some people who actually
participated and were part of our court
group larry davidson
uh clarion gerald is here
uh so i'm just happy that we have
colleagues in the room as well yeah
that's great and yeah hey guys feel free
to ask any questions
i think tai says she has one more so
i feel bad that we are monopolizing anna
so anyone else and you know it's getting
on in time so before we wrap up if
anyone else
has any questions please uh uh type them
up meanwhile ty go ahead you said you
had one more question yeah sure thank
you so you quoted you you offered some
really evocative quotations from
participants but i think the most
poignant one in my opinion was the one
about the person who had suffered from
psychosis big psychotic episode and that
i really needed misquoting now perhaps
but i really needed
other people
and
you know uh he or she was was isolated
as the rest of us were at some point
right especially early on
and so building on what you were just
discussing before with priya you
probably don't want to
delve into the realm of
policy but
what could it look like were there
countries where it may be societies
where this this didn't happen the same
way where you know if people are are
suffering we're gregarious creatures and
we need one another and yet we became
i guess perforce you know so atomized
you know really i mean we weren't
allowing our children to play with other
children and for a long time we're still
you know really kind of in this just
being so cautious you know and and
being um
i guess somehow
uh
viewing
in the worst instances viewing one
another as vectors of of disease and and
you know kind of being so
anxious about
about reaching out to others and that of
course you know
has its has really deleterious effects
on an individual and a society
do you know of of places where that
didn't uh happen to that extent and
people were able to kind of live a
better model of it
i actually so that is one and i'm i'm
curious to know about that as well and i
think we'll know more once uh you know
more research starts coming out but what
comparing you know the different
responses reactions the different social
uh distancing measures the different
shelter in place like i think it will
take time for us to understand like what
the right choices were
i will say that in terms of you know our
population the population of people with
you know psychiatric diagnosis as you
saw
that is already clear that they were
disproportionately and and died
disproportionately compared to the
general population so that's something
for us to consider that you know
actually a psychiatric diagnosis a
serious mental illness does predict
worse outcomes
for this and we also know that in terms
of access to services
uh people you know who were receiving
services
and we had a lot of people talk about
the suddenly stop receiving services or
uh um you know the services that you
know replace the in-person
um
services that they got were just not you
know sufficient to to help them
and so
i think there is
you know when i when i talk
about conceptualizing and framing
suffering suffering in psychiatric terms
or or in pathologizing poverty i also
don't want i want to make sure that we
don't
um
you know forget the people who are
getting services and are being helped by
services and what
you know uh
and how access to services actually
suffered
um with the pandemic and we saw that
with
other health conditions as well you know
that people just didn't go for their
checkups and didn't go for their
screenings and and how
how much of a broader impact and general
health
um
the whole pandemic had
thank you
sure
um
let's see if there are any more
questions um
if not we should um let me just wait and
see uh there anything else that's come
up with the q and a
note uh let's thank uh anna for
wonderful talk and a great project we
wish you
the best in continuing with this very
very important line of research
and uh
and i also want to thank tai and
guy and
ryan today for helping us with the uh av
and recording
and transcription services uh throughout
this academic year i want to thank you
all for coming to this talk and for your
support of all the events that we've
been holding this year
so um
bye everyone have a wonderful summer and
see you all back in the fall
in person where we hope to share
um you know our back to our tradition of
sharing lovely meals and
scholarship
and barbara i wanted to say a special
thank you and bye to you
and
hope that we will see you in person in
the fall
and
have the joy of your company
a thai did you want to add anything
how could i build on that okay
of course but thank you so much anna
just
i mean i'm just struck by how
um impactful your work is and how needed
and necessary and so grateful that we
had the opportunity to to have you as a
frankie fellow and uh thank you for what
you're doing it's critical
thank you mrs frankie thank you
so here's uh giving you a big round of
applause from all of us yeah
thank you so much okay bye everyone bye
bye take care yeah bye